welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
amazing spider-man 2 the 2014 sequel
with some of the best effects best
spider-man suit design
and plot with such a death wish for gwen
stacy that it reads like the mind of a
deranged murderer
gonna kill ya just kidding gonna kill ya
just kidding
gonna kill ya just kidding actually
never mind you're dead
and yes there are two separate psycho
research walls in this movie
one of them randomly scored that song
for you
for you movies never get enough
of this song that sucks there's been a
lot of hate on this movie over the years
but trust me
it is still worth revisiting you asked
for this and i found
a ton of fascinating visual details in
it easter eggs plans for what insanity
might have been
some of these details might make you
appreciate it more others might make you
say
wow there was even more of a method to
this madness and i realized and i'm glad
we got off this secret train powered by
arcade tokens the film opens inside a
clock
the cogs and gears of richard parker's
wristwatch foreshadowing the
machinations of the clock tower that
sealed the fate of gwen stacy the
character whose death
these two movies obsessively thwip
toward like its predecessor this movie
deepens the conspiracy of peter's father
in ozcorp
revisiting the night of the previous
film's prologue fittingly the parker's
plane's descent
transitions into the plunge of peter's
spider logo
as he swings down to stop crazy paul
giamatti
he is the spidey villain the rhino
evidenced by the rhinos on his boxers
and rather than immediately stopping his
deadly plutonium truck theft when he
could
peter [ __ ] talks and gives rhino time to
murder
more drivers and pedestrians in that
alley you can pinpoint the second
they'll never be able to walk again so
you know peter can get a few more laughs
for his reel
peter's ringtone is the 60s animated
spider-man theme
because he's somehow aware of his own
franchise and he misses gwen's death
foreshadowing graduation speech
i know we all think that we're immortal
we're supposed to feel that way
yeah right and stan lee cameos i think i
know that guy
peter keeps hallucinating dennis leary
everywhere after he warned peter at the
end of the last film
leave quinn
and so they break up and peter's now
single and ready to peter tingle the
nerd he deprives of a character building
life experience
never learns to appreciate pain and thus
stupidly walks directly into gunfire in
the final scene and peter glues the
kid's project with webbing that will
dissolve a few hours later he
failed this child edie bryant cameos is
a statue of liberty and then peter
catches his police truck and
exits frame right which i kind of love
this it's an homage to buster keaton's
move in the movie cops
max still in future electro celebrates
his own birthday
with a cake with green and yellow
frosting and lightning bolt shapes of
course
a nod to electro's color scheme and you
might not have noticed how the
background of this apartment also
reflects these colors
the green window and the yellow
lampshade peter mentioned selling photos
of the daily bugle that would really
help if that guy would pay you a fair
wage
well james no jameson facebook pays me a
fair wage if it was 1961.
he says 1961 which is the year right
before spider-man debuted in the comics
in 1962. now jameson himself does not
appear in the film but the daily bugle
does a few times
dylan's boss is bj novak as alistar
smythe who in the comics is a villain
who controls the spider slayer robot
assassins
harry osborne meets his alien father
norman
dying from a family curse and when he
dies a green light
scans his body and then a medical worker
rolls in a
cryo container that is because there was
a scrapped plan for the third movie in
the series
to preserve norman's head and for him to
regenerate
along with gwen and her father using
peter's blood serum
possibly in three there was this idea at
one point that
spider-man would be able to take this
formula and regenerate the people in his
life that had died
captain stacey would come back even
bigger and episode three and i was like
let's go and i think i need to see that
now chris cooper's head rattling around
and an ice cooler
avenge me boy and uh open this white
cloth for me cause i can't get my teeth
around it peter emails photos to j jonah
jameson passed emails from james and
collins photos crap
and offering only 10 bucks for the whole
set another email from aunt may reminds
him to pick up eggs a call back to him
for getting and later remembering the
eggs in the previous film
and an email from oscorp hr suggesting
peter has been applying for jobs there
to no avail
probably because we don't want our
former employees son investigating all
the [ __ ] we did to him
max falls in the eel tank and somehow
the electricity fixes
the gap in his teeth which i love
because jimmy fox didn't need the gap in
his teeth to begin with
they just gave it to him so that these
eels could fix it in this moment
happy birthday in harry's boardroom is
felicity jones as
felicia she was being set up as felicia
hardy black cat but it didn't pan out of
course
so she moved on to star wars stories and
immediately killed her off population
peter and harry catch up which peter
hates so much he casually tries to kill
himself
and they skip those stones which peter
aces because you know he's spider-man
but harry kerr plunks like an idiot but
you can see it's because his hands
have already begun twitching which his
father warned him about
how your hands started to twitch yet
electro attacks times square and notice
how spectator barriers have been set up
which you know
i hate to be nitpicky because you know
all movies can do this but this would
imply
preparation for onlookers we actually
see this again in the final scene
cops why would you set up anything for
people to stand there and watch don't
erect a
barrier people need to keep running for
blocks and not turn around
they're going to die that's definitely
not a safe radius for all the bullets
and lightning that are flying around and
similarly when electro attacks
those red steps the people there are
fleeing up those steps despite the fact
that there is nowhere for them to go at
the top these stairs don't lead anywhere
and you know these people know this
because
later they know to flee down those steps
see this sequence
was not designed to be a true threat
really it is no deeper than a mere
visual spectacle a light show with a
literal stage and a literal audience and
that
superficial aspect seeing the screen
switch from electro to spider-man
is what turns max on peter in this
moment peter's research on what
roosevelt refers to
brings up a photo of the roosevelt
island tramway a nod to the final battle
with green goblin in the first sam
rainey spider-man film
and i know i already bashed the psycho
research wall but god damn it peter went
to the effort of printing out
fdr's face on separate post-it note size
squares and then piecing them back
together
i guess because fdr's big checkerboard
face is
the key to this movie she's the key
but before i continue thank you to bang
energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free has zero calories yet it
tastes great
with over 20 different flavors to choose
from one of those great flavors is froze
rose
has that great fruity taste of rose wine
but will make you come back to life as
if you were a fictional immortal
still capable of dying but really
nothing can keep you down
check out bang on instagram you can get
25 off your order
at bang energy.com when you use the code
newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors
you can also get clothing fitness
supplements all kinds of stuff to be
your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25
off at bangdashenergy.com using the code
newrockstars25
harry osborn similarly unlocks a trinket
to his daddy's secrets oscorp
secret projects that include if you look
closely dr connor's file
and dr morbius file which referred to
doctor connors from previous from and
michael morvious the living vampire
coming soon next year with hunka hucka
jared leto there's also
venom storage and experiment oct 32a
which could be nods to venom and doctor
octopus
there's also a bunch of projects in
australia oahu new zealand manchester
those could refer plans to introduce
international bounty hunter craven
hunter
actually there's that saber-toothed
tiger skull with a gold teeth in its
room
could be another bounty or trophy that
craven gave to norman in the past and in
the archive video of richard parker and
norman osborne you can already see
norman's hands starting to twitch there
too a sign of his illness starting to
set in
the youtube video peter researches has
zero down votes
yet the blue bar should put that like
ratio somewhere in the low 80s
i know this because that bar is my
master harry tells peter he needs
spider-man's blood for its self-healing
properties
he can do everything else a spider can
another sort of nod
that animated theme song does whatever a
spider can now the first moment gwen
meets harry it's a jump scare for her
gwen stacey oh my god
sorry gwen is right to be afraid this is
the psycho that will later snatch her up
out of nowhere and lead to her death
which will be a much faster drop than
the descent in their elevator here
the ravencroft institute is a key
supervillain prison in the marvel comics
a prison for supervillains in the
criminally insane it is run by dr
ashley kafka as it is in the comics and
he plays johann strauss's beautiful blue
danube most famously used to evoke
humanity's great leaps forward into
sci-fi
in films like 2001 a space odyssey and
recently with another blue freak lab
experiment dr manhattan and watchmen
spider-man refuses to give harry his
blood
you're a fraud spider-man and peter does
some national treasure [ __ ]
finds his daddy's secret train lab and
learns it was richard's
own dna infused with the spiders making
it peter's destiny to become spider-man
people will say i'm a monster
for what i've done and maybe they're
right uh-huh the real crime against
nature here was going back to the
sacred bloodline trope instead of the
this could have happened to anybody
factor that has always made spider-man
great meanwhile harry manages to
overpower two armed guards and free
electro
and then uses making to access norman's
basement which is cast
in green light for the you know
the color the goblin you get it now in
this basement are six
chambers or six among which you could
see doc ock arms and later with gustav
fears
you can see a vulture wings and a rhino
exoskeleton
the end credits show flashes of all of
these sinister six figures
along with nods to craven hunter and
maybe chameleon
for a planned drew goddard directed
sinister six film that was scrapped
and as harry transforms we get this nice
sweaty dany shoulder blade roll
let's loop that for some puke porn
please
as peter chases lecture around the city
i love this he climbs up his own web
during the swing
now again the effects of action in this
movie pretty solid
but unfortunately for some parts of this
battle we don't really want to see it
like you know when electro pukes
lightning on him
and of course infamously when he turned
the power plant grid columns into a
xylophone
i hate this song which i gotta say like
those crowd barriers
is mostly weird just because it implies
illogical preparation
like for this to work elektra would have
had to come here hours earlier
and slam himself against these tuning
them so that he could later play a
nursery rhyme song
like he must have had a friend to help
him
not quite my temple but gwen arrives to
help and on this day she is wearing a
green jacket and a purple skirt
the exact same clothes that she wears
during her famous death in the comics
but
her death is a not much of a surprise
it's telegraphed pretty overtly
nobody makes my decisions for me all
right nobody
this is my choice it's interesting how
gwen's face was
off screen for the line this is my
choice almost as if emma stone had to
come back and to redub the audio in
attempt by the filmmakers to
soften the blow over death and make it
make a bit more sense but the damage has
already been done
because in this movie gwen's death is
just a factor of a totally unmotivated
conflict between peter harry and electro
it really just happens because the
script in the studio said it has to
which is really the core issue for both
of these movies see really the curses of
peter parker's life are all meant to
come from
chaos and randomness but this series
tries to streamline that mythology
his powers the death of uncle ben when
stacy's death they all play out like
pre-destined clockwork we actually see
the gears moving both metaphorically and
literally in the opening images but
sadly it cheapens gwyn's death by just
making her feel like another cog in that
machine
now yes it's kind of cool that the clock
tower freezes on 121
the issue number gwen died in the comics
but the camerawork doesn't really do
anything to make it subtle or like
discoverable
the clock hand just clangs with a duh
kind of like they
started with this idea and then worked
their way backwards from it
and then never really wanted the
audience to see other possible futures
now some
accused peter of not mourning gwen long
enough in the final minutes of this
movie but actually we do see him at her
grave for a full year's worth of seasons
passing around him really the bigger
issue is how peter returns to being
spider-man
unchanged from the first act he's even
fighting the same villain
the one new move he pulls is using a
manhole lid to deflect rhino's
projectiles and smack him with it which
you could say is a callback to him using
the lid against electro in the power
plant but even that move technically was
before gwen arrived to change his whole
attack strategy
and teach him a thing or two it's almost
as if the studio was saying look you get
more spider-man are you happier nerds
really the best lesson the studio
learned from this was simply to
surrender the character to
another studio that knows what they're
doing when it comes to fan service now
does this mean sony is incapable of good
spider-man stories absolutely not
spider-man into the spider-verse is
considered by many to be the best
spider-man movie and that was
all sony at the end of the day i am
grateful for these two amazing
spider-man films
there's a lot to love in both
historically i just find it uncanny that
this came out the same year as my two
favorite mcu films captain america the
winner soldier and guardians of the
galaxy
because this proves to superhero
filmmakers that even in this modern era
success in this genre is not a given
but for my hotter takes on these movies
and to join us for our next watch along
join our official discord server by
becoming a patron at patreon.com
newrockstars follow me on instagram
eaboss follow me rockstars on socials
and subscribe for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you